The Joe Rogan experience,
so we're approaching like the place
we're going to do the afternoon,
you know,
landing spot,
which is just kind of sky
deck overlooking the jungle.
And I wanted to take my shoes
off as I walked up there.
So I just fucking did it.
I took my shoes off,
didn't worry about the
mosquitoes and that felt great.
Just feeling the grass
and the mud on my feet.
It was a short walk.
So there wasn't any crazy
shit going on in the,
in the brush or anything
I had to worry about.
We get up there and um,
I go to lie down and I had taken again,
I'd taken the most,
what you might've taken at any point ever.
So I'm more blasted than I had been the
whole trip because I got eight ounces
instead of six.
And I go to lie down and I'm pondering
this idea of choice a lot and fears and
feeling pretty good because
everything that's happened,
I was passed these tests and I see this
little ant crawling towards me to my
right hand side and I look and I go,
fuck,
there's an aunt coming.
And so I totally broke
my train of thought.
Stood straight up,
and then I look back at
that and I just realized,
Holy Shit,
I just let that little fucking aunt have
the power over me to make me sit up.
I lose my train of consciousness
and completely move on his behalf.
And it wasn't like a deadly poisonous
and it was just an ant and I.
Then I thought to myself,
how many other these little things
that are truly ants in our existence,
fears,
worries,
Paranoia's relationships that you feel
crunchy about in this certain way or
crunchy.
I like something that's uncomfortable
to you in a situation or that you're
projecting and you're simulator is
worried about these little things when in
reality or no more than these
ants which are harmless,
caused you to make,
to choose actions that
aren't in your best interest,
you know,
and we,
because we give them power,
we give them the power
over us to make us move.
They do have power
and they could do just as good.
I mean they can have a show.
You did it from your fucking living
room 12 years ago and look at you today
and if let's say that they
somehow coopt us and we sell out,
right?
They'll some,
someone else's company
also replaced Alex Jones.
He's waiting.
He's in Austin,
Texas.
You say you're the number one,
but I've got the statistics.
I've got the documents right here,
but show you're a liar.
You're a new world order puppet.
He seems like he's out there
working for the people.
He's not working for the people.
He worked for MSNBC.
Ladies and gentlemen,
you don't get to Msnbc unless you sell
your soul to David Ickes reptilians.
That was awesome.
I've never,
I've never heard you do that.
That's,
that was amazing.
I've known that dude for a long time.
I've,
Alex Jones in 1999.
I did a,
a DVD in Austin,
Texas and Alex Jones
and I put on Bush masks.
I was a Bush Jr.
He was bush senior and we,
uh,
we,
we were these outfits and ran around the
capital and it was called the live from
the belly of the beast.
It was rigHt before
bush senior got elected.
And uh,
I've,
I've known him for even before then.
I've known that guy for a long time.
My theory is that alex
is a false operation.
Really?
Yeah.
Is there a real,
a real theory?
Kind of half kidding.
Half serious.
But you say that because
you're trying to fuck with me.
What he's trying to do right
now is coal up my mind.
I'm sitting here in austin,
Texas.
I'm smoking cigarettes
and drinking whiskey.
I'm getting fucking crazy.
I'm trying to protect people from
the government as black helicopters.
Their flight over my dodge charger.
That's fucking funny.
Tom rhodes pissing this thing.
That's not the bathroom.
Yeah,
that's not the bathroom.
He's in there.
I've done that a lot.
Have you?
Bingo is caught me so many times trying
to go into the closet and the hotel room
to take a piss that you go,
well that's the amount of times you've
woken up and found me how many times
they've pissed off over my own
shit and never knew about it.
I'm trying to remember.
I do it all the time.
The humidity,
I guess.
I'm trying to remember
who told me this story,
but somebody opened up the drawer
and they pissed on their sock drawer.
They open up,
they went to their dresser and they pulled
their sock drawer open and they just
pissed in there and I'm like,
what the fuck did you
think your sock drawer was?
The toilet.
I've been on the.
I'm sure you've done this dog
peed in the corner of a hotel.
That's why we're talking about.
We saw you go through the wrong door
thinking you're going to win when you peed
in the corner of a lot of hotel.
A few of them just being plastered,
like signed it.
I was there.
How many times bingos caught me doing
that versus how many times she didn't wake
up that I did that and
didn't know I did that.
That's those extra two shots.
Well,
your brain says it's over.
doug stanhope you say,
fuck it is.
I was plastered in Ireland years
ago and I went out the room door.
I thought I was going into.
I was just drunk and half awake.
I just needed to pee and I'm in the
fucking hallway naked and I was banging on
the door and my hand girlfriend get come.
What the fuck are you
doing out there again?
Did that mother fucking door?
We already have this on a podcast.
Hennigan did that right there.
My manager and Henry Phillips both have
stories walking out thinking they're
going into the bathroom,
walking out naked and the door shuts me.
Amanda both naked in the
fucking hallway going.
Then you instantly become john ritter.
I haven't been.
There's no way.
That's not comedy.
You know?
I don't have identification.
If you do like a 20 year bid in a hotel,
you're working in a hotel for 20 years.
Some who's coming down naked.
How many dudes come down naked during
your entire career holding their cock and
balls is going?
Brian,
when he went into a like a locker,
a housekeeping door that was open,
grabbed a a sheet or whatever,
put it over his dick.
I walked down to the hotel and
they just gave him the key.
He didn't.
They didn't say id or anything.
Ideology is.
I mean,
I,
I don't remember who said it,
but it's,
it's the enemy of free thinking,
[inaudible].
You get in these ideological clusters
and then anything outside of this thing,
these predetermined patterns of behavior
that you've done to subscribe to
anything becomes forbidden.
It becomes you.
You can't even entertain it.
You can't even approach the idea.
You see it with everything
you see with atheism.
You see it with,
you see it with any isms,
with feminism,
with the men's rights.
You see it with people who
subscribe to the right people,
subscribed to the left.
Any variables that don't fit into their
equation that they've already suBscribed
to,
they don't want to be labeled as that
other side and anytime they don't want to
be labeled,
they start ignoring any evidence or any
ideas that don't fit within this really
rigid description.
That's exactly right.
I mean that is.
You hit the nail on the head,
joe.
Weird.
Exactly right.
People get locked into these ideological
paradigms and then from that point on,
basically their perspective as modified
more by emotion and rationality more by
their feelings rather
than real information.
You're the only person
that's ever come in,
sat down and said,
oh,
this is good.
I'm getting a cortisol rush.
He said,
you're getting a cortisol rush
from the feeling of about.
Actually,
I could have gotten a little more detail,
but please do.
You know,
so that feeling of anxiety,
you know,
that lIke you get before you go onstage,
I mean,
you're a comedian,
I'm sure you're familiar with that.
You actually are expressing a
chemical called dane orphan and uh,
this is an endogenous chemical in your
brain and it binds to something called
the kappa opioid receptor.
It's kinda like the counter of the
endorphin which binds to the new opioid
receptor.
So the endorphins are the feel good.
Well,
it's nemesis is the dynorphins,
which is that anxiety,
like feeling.
So,
but here's the interesting part,
that anxiety,
like feeling that you feel before
you're going to do something like you're
really,
that you care about or that's
kind of anxiety provoking for me.
Public speaking does it,
I,
I get it right before I'm going to do it,
you know,
give a talk or something,
um,
or do a podcast in front of,
you know,
500,000 people.
Um,
so that dynorphins binding
to the cap opioid receptor.
What it does is it upregulates the mule
opioid receptor so that after you get
that anxiety feeling,
you have a better endorphin rush because
you upregulate the new opioid receptors
which bind to the endorphins,
the feel good ones,
and you actually become
sensitized to them.
So there's a biological mechanism by which
having that anxiety actually does you
good.
So it's kind of like a stress at first,
but then later on you're,
you get,
do you feel better and
you're more relaxed.